Ariana Grande cuddles up with Mac
Miller's dog while BTS take over
late-night and the UN this is the daily
dandy but of course I'm down to dedicate
it to BTS can you tell him in the army
all right the guys are on a bit of a
media blitz this week they stopped by
Good Morning America today and well they
made this girl's life I don't blame you
kid
now the group's leader RM also opened up
about the band's historic appearance at
the United Nations earlier this week
where they talked about their love
yourself campaign with UNICEF no matter
who you are where are you from your skin
color your gender identity just speak
yourself find your name and find your
voice I trained for it like like a
thousand times like I imagined it and I
think I did it okay but yeah but I was
holding the paper you know the comments
were on and I was like my hands were
like like shaking like like thousand
signs like for a second so yeah it
wasn't it was a nervous thing but you
know it was like a like the best moment
in my life we have learned to love
ourselves so now I urge you to speak
yourself well their message of self-love
and positivity is one that has played
out in everything they do including of
course their music and we love yourself
trilogy something they told me about
earlier this year my final goal of the
whole my whole life is to love myself
like for real because you know it's
always a hardest and sometimes compare
ourselves to others and you know like
sometimes get really depressed or you
know so but in love like we should be we
should be you know take off the mask
be true to who we are BTS and their fans
also took over the Tonight Show with
Jimmy Fallon on Tuesday where Jimmy
challenged them to an epic dance-off and
fortnight fashion
hey guys me with BTU absolute raggedy
fortnight dance challenge get support
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
alright switching gears now ariana
grande is cuddling up to someone that
was super special to her late ex Matt
Miller ari took to Instagram on Monday
playing around with the cutest Brown
pitbull as it turns out the dog is my R
and Mac Miller's dog he adopted in
January of last year when he and Ariana
were still together re caption the video
all the kisses happy fall we don't know
if she's adopted Mac's dog following his
death but we do know she's a dog lover
re already has six pups of her own if
you're wondering how ariana is holding
up these days since Mac's death she
tweeted over the weekend everything will
be okay everything will be okay her rep
told et in a statement she is going to
take some much-needed time to heal and
mend and on that note I'm sending
positive vibes your way make sure you
guys come back tomorrow for another dose
of daily